geil der hat einen richtigen Clip
gedreht Fragen an dich fünf Fragen
so ich bin Goran und ich bin Adem will
kommen aus Mannheim und wir haben fünf
Fragen an dich wenn es zu viel ist Frage
ein wann kommt dein Buch raus genau mich
interessieren ein buchusgebracht aber
ich glaub deine
Geschichte B bester raer sein Buch
rausbringen nicht irgend so ein Opfer ja
oder genau also mein Buch ich habe mal
spaßeshalber gesagt das wird heißen ich
bin jetzt Anfang 30 die Geheimnisse
eines Teeny Stars oder so nee das wird
sicher noch ein besseren Namen kriegen
ich würde gerne ein Buch machen aber das
Happy End fehlt halt noch wenn jetzt der
Schluss vom Buch ist ja und dann habe
ich ein Mixtape gemacht das passt nicht
so richtig also wartet ab ich muss noch
ein mal abräumen und dann kann man das
machen dann kann ich ein Buch drüber
schreiben wie man als Jugendlicher ganz
hoch kommt dann vielleicht zwischendurch
sogar runterfällt aber durch harte
Arbeit und so wieder an die Spitze
gelangt und ich hoffe das wird sich
irgendwann realisieren lassen und zweite
Frage ist bezüglich freezy bom 2 weil
bei dem ein kam ja ein T-Shirt raus ob
bei den zwei irgendwie Jogginghose dabei
rauskommen weil T-Shirt mit Jogginghose
W Br
das wäre echt eine coole Idee da eine
Jogginghose beizulegen leider oder was
heißt leider dieses mixape kommt
offiziell raus über mein Label Sony 313
und das kommt ganz normal im Laden raus
da wird's jetzt kein Goodie dabei geben
das wird einfach eine CD sein dafür habt
ihr auch eine bessere CD richtig mit CD
Case und nicht wie beim ersten in so
einer paphülle sondern einfach ein
offizielles Release ist das halt ein
bisschen kleiner wie ein Album Release
aber ein kleines feines zu Weihnachten
gibt euch das dritte Frage ist von mir
ist mit K1 noch alles gut weil da war ja
früher bei GD und jetzt ist der bei erst
guter Junge ja also von meiner Seite ist
mit K alles gut der hat sich halt dafür
entschieden bei Bushido zu bleiben ist
halt seine Entscheidung kann ich dem
nicht vorwerfen ich wünsche dem alles
Gute ich mache halt mein eigenes Ding
und wir bei GD halten zusammen wenn er
da sich nicht zu gehörig fühlt soll er
es lassen ne dann viertens wann kommst
wieder nach manim eo wir haben dich ja
hier vermisst ja
man Konzert wä geil man können mal hier
wieder Party machen ja Leute Mannheim
und auch alle anderen Städte vor allem
ich nenne sie immer GD Städte weil
besonders die Städte in denen wir gut
ankommen die will ich alle besuchen
nächstes Jahr ich bin schon dran und
versuche eine Minitour zu organisieren
ich wäre auch interessiert an einer
fetten GD Tour komplett mit dem German
Dream Team das können wir alles
realisieren das wird alles auf euch
zukommen macht euch keine Sorgen und
letzte Frage ist driften schon die Leute
im Auto ja wann kommt dein nächstes
Album darauf warten wir wie gespannt
weil h hast du zwei treue Fans wir
kaufen auf jeden Fall und GD ist the
crew man also erstmal grüße ich euch
beide Jungs ich finde cool dass ihr
Käufer seid und dass ihr damit auch uns
unterstützt ein neues Album kommt auch
hoffentlich nächstes Jahr es hängt auch
bisschen mit dem mixtap jetzt zusammen
was über Sony rauskommt
freezy bumbay 2 weil damit spiele ich
auch bisschen von mein alten Vorschuss
wieder ein und wenn das ganz okay läuft
was ich denke oder wovon ich jetzt
erstmal ausgeben will dann gibt's
natürlich auch nächstes Jahr ein geiles
neues fettes freezy Album ja man beste
Hal tschüss ciao ciao ihr
lieben